in the ever evolving landscape of
digital world blogging has become more
than just a personal online Journal it's
a powerful tool for businesses and
individuals to establish a robust online
presence however the journey from
creating compelling content to ensuring
its visibility on search engines
involves understanding and implementing
effective blog SEO strategies in this
video
on blogging in SEO we will have a look
at what is blog SEO why is blog SEO
important and how to optimize your blog
for Su but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
press the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn in a world
where a dedicated manager struggle to
meet sales Target due to a lack of
product awareness the Need For Change
became evident enter the Su expert a
professional hired to transform the game
tasked with making the product more
visible and enticing to potential
customers the Su expert delved into the
realm of blog SEO so what is blog SEO
blog SEO or search engine optimizations
refers to the practices and techniques
employed to enhance blogs visibility on
search engines search engine result
Pages or in other words it refers to the
process of optimizing your blog content
to make it more visible and rank higher
in search engine results by implementing
various SEO techniques bloggers can
attract organic traffic to their
websites thereby increasing their online
presence and reaching a wider audience
the ultimate goal is to make the blog
more accessible and appealing to both
search engines and human readers as
search engines constantly evolve staying
updated with the latest SEO practices is
crucial for maintaining and improving a
blog's search visibility now let's
explore the importance of blog SEO why
is blog SEO important so blog SEO is
crucial for several reasons first one is
improved visibility blog SEO enhances
the chances of your blog appearing in
top positions on search engine result
Pages scps increasing the likelihood of
users discovering and visiting your blog
second is increase traffic and
engagement higher visibility in search
results can lead to influx of organic
traffic as users are more likely to
click on the links that appear at the
top of the search results this increased
traffic can also result in higher
engagement with your content next is
enhanced user experience Su optimization
often involves improving the overall
user experience of your blog such as
faster loading times mobile making it
more user friendly and accessible next
is attraction of quality backlinks
well-optimized blogs are more likely to
attract quality backlinks from other
reputable websites these back links
serve as a vote of confidence in the
eyes of search engines contributing to
the blog's authority and credibility so
this was something about the importance
of blog SEO now just a quick info for
you if you want to upskill yourself
master digital marketing skills and
landar your dream job or grow in your
career then you must explore simply
learns cohort of various digital
marketing programs simply learns offers
various certification and post-graduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
spj Purdue and meta through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like search engine
marketing strategies for paid campaigns
analytical Roi and dozen others that's
not all you also get the opportunity to
work on multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in Top Tire
product companies and academian from top
universities after completing these
courses thousands of learners have
transitioned into digital marketing role
as a fresher or moved onto a higher
paying job role and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comments and
description box to find the digital
marketing program that fits your
experience and areas of Interest all
right now let's understand how to
optimize your blog for SEO optimizing
your blog for search engines is
essential for increasing its visibility
and attraction organic traffic Etc by
implementing effective SEO strategies
you can improve your blogs chances of
ranking higher in search engine results
first is observing Google search results
one of the first step in optimizing your
blog for SEO is to observe Google search
results analyze the top ranking blogs in
your Niche and identify the keywords and
content structure that are driving their
success this will provide valuable
insights into the type of content that
resonates with your target audience and
the SEO strategies that are working
effectively next is finding keywords for
each post keyword research is a
fundamental aspect of blogu identify
relevant keywords and phrases that are
commonly searched by your target
audience tools like Google Keyword
Planner SCM rush and ahrs that is
ahrefs can help you discover high value
keywords with reasonable search volumes
and low competition incorporating these
keywords strategically into your blog
post can significantly improve their
visibility in search results all right
now the third is optimizing your blog
post when creating blog post ensure that
they are well structured and contain
high quality relevant content use
headings subheadings and bullet points
to organize your content and make it
more readable additionally optimize your
images by using descriptive file names
and ALT tags to improve their visibility
in image search results following this
there is title and tags craft compiling
and relevant titles for your blog post
incorporating primary keywords to
attract both readers and search engines
furthermore utilize meta tags including
meta descriptions and meta titles to
provide concise summaries of your
content and entice users to click
through to your blog next one is on page
and off-page optimization onpage
optimization involves optimizing
individual web pages to improve their
search engine rankings the this includes
optimizing metatags internal linking and
ensuring a seamless user experience off
page optimization on the other hand
focuses on building backlinks from
reputable websites social media
promotion and other external factors
that can influence your blog search
engine rankings following this we have
backlinks acquiring high quality
backlinks from authorized websites is
crucial for improving your blogs SEO
backlinks from reputable sources act as
a vote of confidence in the eyes of
search engines signaling The credibility
and relevance of your content to attract
these valuable backlinks focus on
creating content that is not only
informative and engaging but also
sharable content that provides unique
insights addresses common challenges or
offers innovative solutions is more
likely to be linked to by other websites
in addition to creating compelling
content engaging Outreach efforts can
significantly boosted backlink profile
building relationship with other
bloggers and website owners in your
Niche can led to collaborative
opportunities and natural backlink
placements at last we have internal
links utilizing internal linking to
connect related content within your blog
this not only helps users navigate your
websites more effectively but also
distributes link Equity throughout your
blog improving the visibility of
individual post and Pages blogging in
SEO is a powerful tool for enhancing the
visibility and reach of your blog by
implementing the strategies outlined
above bloggers can op optimize their
content for search engines attract
organic traffic and establish their blog
as a valuable resource within their
Niche embracing blog SEO is essential
for staying competitive in digital
landscape and maximizing the impact of
your blogging efforts all right guys
with that we have come to the end of
this video If you like this video please
give it a thumbs up I hope it really
help you all thanks for watching stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of programs and set yourself on the path
to Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here